Here's part 2 for our math quill guide for unit 5. I mentioned learning about
entering numbers is scientific notation. Let's see how we can do this. To enter
a number in scientific notation. You'll want to type in the leading number or
decimal followed by the asterisk symbol. This asterisk symbol will create a dot
or a multiplication in between our first number and our power of 10. Be sure you
don't type x for the multiplication sign. We'll think it's a variable instead.
Next, you'll type in the number 10 followed by the carrot symbol and then the
exponent of 5. So now you try it out. You can follow these keystrokes to enter
this number in scientific notation and then, try these on your own. Enter your
answers here and good luck.